- You know some stuff about
me that's pretty dark.
I know some stuff about
you that's pretty weird.
I mean a lot of the stuff we know is
probably not TV friendly.
(laughs)
(bouncing music)
- [Mathew] I don't know if I
wrote it big enough, though.
- [Thomas] We'll find out. Ready?
- [Mathew] You want to show it now?
- My answer is
"Stretching out like Richard Simmons".
- [Mathew] I misspelled something.
- Smoking and/or lounging.
- Lying on a couch.
We do know each other!
- We know each other very well.
- Fudge!
What do we got?
- Fuck.
- Oh! Yeah! I had the
upbeat version of that.
- [Thomas] I think it's fun.
You got that sort of a Canadian flare.
Is it "clusterfuck"?
Like, "This has turned into
a real clusterfuck, eh?"
- No, that's not a swear word.
- What do you got?
- Fuck face.
- Oh, fuck face. I was close.
- "Clusterfuck" you thought
was my favorite swear word?
- I don't know. I was just
trying to think of a word.
I don't hear you swear very much.
- I swear a lot.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Not at me.
- No, internally.
- No.
- [Mathew] You should hear
what I'm saying right now.
- What is it?
- [Woman Offscreen] Yoga and juggling.
- Yeah, very different.
If you think I'm good at yoga,
you should see me juggle.
[Thomas] Look how quickly
I started writing.
- [Mathew] I don't know
what my secret talent is.
- Want me to tell you?
(laughs)
Show yours first.
Complaining.
Or tennis.
[Thomas] I really was one.
It's "Not Most Likely to Have Jazz Hands".
What'd you put?
No, I was voted "Most Likely to Succeed".
- You were?
- I was.
- I was voted "Most Talkative".
- There you go. I could see that.
[Mathew] You're writing
much longer than I am.
[Thomas] Well I drew a little
picture to your reaction
to the thing, too.
What did you write?
- Well, I can't tell you.
- I wrote green things.
- I wrote fish.
- I forgot you hate fish.
- I hate fish.
- I know that for a while I was buying you
a green juice every day and then
one day you said "Don't
ever do that again".
- Yeah, that's true.
- I honestly can't think of anything.
I can't think of anything.
- Look what I wrote.
- I know. I'm just a positive person.
[Thomas] Come on.
[Mathew] Oh.
[Thomas] Uh oh, did we stumble?
I'm gonna hold mine up over here.
[Women Offscreen] Now see. Let's review.
- Hazel. Very close.
- I'm close and you're right.
- Yeah.
- This is going to sound
sort of tacky and small time,
but can we keep the markers?
- This is a great marker.
- Amazing markers! Amazing markers!